o lado pessoal de quem fala é o dark já
não cheira um tiro e filhoses tira um
bolinho cheiro é é que ela gosta de
manteiga que nem todos sabem porque já
estamos quase no natal eu adoro natal
porque no natal vocês comem para caraças
que nem no seu ponto dele porque toda a
gente como e como eu não quero passar o
natal sozinho hoje vamos ficar aqui um
jogo bastante interessante que é de
leite lrf joão novela bahia ia levar
neres eu nem sei quem é esta mulher mas
é basicamente um objetivo a ser
conquistado esta da amaro confesso que
não sei se aquilo é uma mulher um homem
tem um qualquer coisa de estranho vocês
vão poder aplicar essa técnica de
conquista das tarumã em qualquer
situação tem trilha da manhã e os bens
certa popularidade do twitter não eu vou
te dizer isto é como é óbvio fui me
encontrar com ariana e até a casa dela
ela está à sua espera
qual o meu deus que gostosa que isto é
não parece um homem ela tá falar o meu
nome rn a sério não vigas que não estava
no menu do jogo nem nada vamos lá entrar
então na cozinha ela acabou nina estava
já a torre pode deixar o último saque
opções agora vamos nos conhecer melhor
um ao outro assim gasto vai ter um
irmãozinho dela em cima da perna
o que nós vamos fazer vamos cumprimentá
lo e vamos dizer alguma coisa
inteligente vamos dizer alguma coisa
divertida o vamos lhe dar um abraço eu
acho que o abraço pra começar é muito
agressivo né
vamos tipo de ser alguma coisa entre
gente porque nós somos suas nexus na
qual eu penso logo existo já confirmou
os fins de vida só para entrarmos bem
assim no clima claro para um convívio
dela do também de uma cadeira e ela
respondeu tudo parece muito inteligente
e eu aposto beijá lo ou então vamos ler
um poema eu não sei subir xará e melhor
forma por favor não baixem alguém na
primeira vez que estão na casa dela a
primeira vez que vem à frente baixa
passava algum tempo nem ler um poema vai
ser chato para caraças ela não vai
custar 65 a subir um poema porque baixar
não é e nem sei se é um homem uma mulher
por isso vamos lá um poema isso é um
livro de poemas que está na mesa perto
do tse é sim pega o rio lê pra mim estão
que estão os títulos dos livros eu vou
escrever este o inchado didô com o
placar no rio
ok eu acho que fiz a escolha certa
porque ela sorriu para mim mesma série
ela com cara do homem basta que o player
do mundo de criança nunca
saber andar lá vamos lá as coisas boas
da vida tu não tem destruir é essa coisa
toda am cosan já tava em o que é ou era
pedra a posição dela mudou ela já sinto
mais à vontade já está a começar a ficar
com escada é isso que nós queremos
eu vou parar então tu és um pouquinho
gento menina ela tava chamado de um gás
com classe e também sabem que acham que
devo eu mesmo eo agora te perguntar o
que nós vamos fazer esta noite eu é que
vou decidir o que vamos fazer é isso nós
podemos ouvir música eu posso deixá-la
eu posso running think it's true era um
puro de mãos no cabelo dela já é um bom
começo o beijo é muito agressiva em 24
pedra papel tesoura não é chato ler um
poema ou ir para outro quarto ok temos
de que duas coisas muito boas ou passar
a mãozinha no cabelo dela ou ir para
outro quarto porque se passar a mãozinha
no cabelo dela eu vou mostrar que quer
alguma coisa mas que também respeito que
sou carinhoso isso for por outro quarto
eo índico logo ele quer fazer qualquer
coisa lei é lei no quarto e ela vai
construir o que eu quero mas também
posso ser muito doce bem pouco ar por
isso eu vou passar o fim do ano passado
os filhos e eu vou passar os filhos no
cabelo dela mil ver hoje não é o caminho
lição caixa o amigo eu devo ser um lugar
lá do óbito
entre estas mãos meu e tudo castro no
discurso e arranjos financeiros no
caminho dela vai ser uma cara de polícia
ela tá gostar mas eu quero saber se
estão um homem primeiro ela tá contente
80 linda isso sabe muito bem e já ariane
o que vamos fazer agora a outra vez já
que surge mais coisas então agora sim
vamos com o quarto agora que já ocupa o
assunto é rock já agora que eu já passei
mãozinha no curso vamos tentar um valor
pouco arthur caleffi show eo around my
house ela quer mostrar a casa dela
podemos ir pra cozinha podemos ir para
as traseiras da casa achou neto vamos
andar podemos ir para o bairro que é o
quarto né ô queremos ouvir música ou
podemos jantar vão explicar o segredo
agora pra conquistar acontecer vocês têm
que sempre pra cozinha porque é um bom
homem um bom xampu - um bom marido tem
que saber cozinhar nem que seja um foco
em outro lado isso você jogar e mesmo a
cozinha elas vão perguntar a inserção
não conhecem esta que se espere impostos
dizem que sim eu sei cozinhar biology
psicóloga e meu tio chance
a raiva vamos lá então pra cozinha esta
é minha cozinha blá blá blá ok o que nós
podemos fazer aqui posso sugerir para ir
jantar ou posso fazer uns bichos podem
encomendar uma pisa podemos beber um
vinho ou podemos fazer qualquer coisa e
ir pra algum lugar eu vou beber um vinho
porque um bom jantar o menu bem vindo e
nós estamos saindo da aula pra ela ficar
acima e doida ela voltou assim agora já
abriu um vinho agora que ela já viu o
vinho que é que nós vamos fazer vamos
comer pisa porque pensa faz as pessoas
polícia além de eu sair pro mil iphones
ela quer uma márcio petrone e quer
pronto eis que uma pizza de pepperoni
chegou o homem de pisa nos véus que
gento - o homem de pizza não quer assim
o homem de fizesse um gordo tá sempre
pisa na movimentação trabalha no piso e
as chamas e véu iphan
aqui está a sua pisa marrom peru é o
último que marrone opel não é má romero
e ariel o orion sair
obrigado é vã mas tu não tens de me
chamar e má fama
nós somos da mesma idade ao meu deus
nunca deixe de acontecer por qualquer um
homem de pisa você já pode pagar porque
sua mãe de pisa foram gastos igual a
isso posso esperar em longas chance de
fazer qualquer coisa com ela porque ela
ficou afastada por eu por isso vocês têm
que ir à porta para mim e eu gosto disso
pode me chamar de adriano e do ovelha
todo custo falar da rua e já estamos com
a mãe de pinça [ __ ] é tão ruim quanto
casa eo fmi âmbar e kauane time mandante
no tonight a nota da itu que já estão
ter comenda pisa - se eu agora tá falar
comigo ato tem uma expressão tais como
estranha o que se passa de errado que
eles fazem de errado na minha porta e
táticos e de pisa e do que contigo é o
melhor a fazer é que é nós vamos ser
sinceros mas também não vamos ter
ordinário ou seja não vamos dizer que
ela estava fazendo possam ali mas também
não vamos ficar calados ou seja vamos
dizer só perguntar assim leva se é
normal a fazer que eu apenas cujo rótulo
anos atrás com ciúmes já recusou ó tu
anos a é caem ou não te preocupes com
evan eu já não dá pizza já a mesa será
que ela já tá mesmo bloco que osmar é o
dexterz tanto fã mulambo chips peixe
soluções israel espera ele é e eu já não
treinava ela faz o homem da pisa nos um
homem de pé e tá ok vamos falar com ela
vamos viver mais vinho vamos comer pizza
ou eo
xiaolian e só uma coisa não entendo
portanto pessoal elogia em sempre as
mulheres porque elas gostam
vamos então dizer o que ela é bonita
onde está aqui ela é bonita eo ar sobre
ti é quente take my eyes off wilza
também na e tal está a ficar um pouco
estranho né e tal clima a irmãozinho
atrás da orelha servem de desculpa eu
vou parar pronto ela ela praticamente
não gosta de ser elogiada
vamos comer pisar um que deliciosa que
está vamos falar com ela do vinho ou dar
um gil agora vamos focar do vinho porque
depois de pisar talento você está bem
vindo é e elas ficam doidos é muito
vinho eu estou ficar bêbada é isso mesmo
que eu quero agora sim pois anotaram
agora vocês vão lá então o elogio que
ela merece
tu és linda já pensaste a impulsionar
nua eu não sei se me perguntares maniche
tentar colo e vamos arriscar agora que
ela está a 5 efeito vené estado falar
sério eu não sou uma modelo a irmãzinha
atrás da orelha tuas gostoso o
suficiente e pode ser obrigado eu vou
pensar nisso
vamos viver mais fininho ou toma tal
qual náutico vá além do oceano ela vai
se limitar toda meu agora vamos clima
pra casa de banho ou vão esperar no
corredor vamos fila clareamento ao meu
girl já está com a bunda fora 18 o
acordo são um direito humano ter um
dalto be the end pela estética ou cinto
tivesse o teu primeiro da aids com a arh
n
este foi o pior encontro que sempre eu
consegui com ela comer pizza e acabei
com ela mandar uma foto e um foi na casa
de banho
ei só vamos ficar porque com isto espero
que vocês tenham gostado estão jogando
em cima e diferente não costumo fazer
estes jogos mas se quiserem mais diga
nos comentários que digam também mais
formas de conseguir conquistar a eneop
aqui brigando quando consegue favorito
fiquem bem e se aproximaram